hi this is James Franco and I'm here
with film courage calm I'm talking to
Karen worden and David Brannon we're
gonna talk about this Palo Alto story's
campaign on IndieGoGo thank you so much
for listening so at what point did you
decide that you were going to use
IndieGoGo to fund this project and we're
also curious why you didn't use
Kickstarter I'm I'm not a specialist on
all of these different you know
Kickstarter or IndieGoGo I think any
gogo was thinking I didn't know my
friend I'm Sean Robertson who is Ed
Norton longtime partner and mother and
his child I think is involved in
IndieGoGo and then told us that that
Edward had raised a money for a
documentary about I think it was a dark
Larry about Obama on IndieGoGo and so it
just I don't know the right to do it I
guess the other thing is you know one of
the very one of the most important
components of this project was that we
didn't want to make I wasn't doing this
to make a profit that we the two goals
that I had were to give these young
filmmakers a chance to make movies and
then also to help the wrong part and I
guess for whatever reason Kickstarter
wouldn't allow us to talk about the
charity I don't know why they had a rule
but they weren't gonna always do that so
that was what another big factor
you